est ce que vous croyez au fait
oui notez bien que je vous pose la
question tout en doutant un peu al
avance de votre réponse il me suffit de
regarder vos têtes
non c'est vrai nom si nous n'étions pas
dans une salle de conférences comme ça
très cosy mais plutôt plutôt dans une
clairière perdu au milieu de la forêt et
que la nuit viennent de tomber
peut-être que ma question résonne ray
différemment à vos oreilles
peut-être que vous ne trouveriez moins
saugrenue est ce que vous croyez au fait
c'est une question que je pose très
souvent quand je vais raconter des
histoires à des groupes d'enfants et là
je dois bien avouer que souvent je suis
un peu déçu oui même un peu dépité parce
que les gamins d'aujourd'hui ne croit
plus beaucoup au fait mais ça ne me
décourage pas un je le raconte quand
même des histoires de fées de l'ue temps
de troll d'elfes et à la fin du
spectacle
je repose ma question alors maintenant
est ce que vous croyez au fait
et si je vois que dans l'assistance il
ya plus de réponses positives et bien je
ne vous cacherai pas que je suis assez
content de moi parce qu'en définitive
c'est un peu ça mon métier faire croire
aux faits
bon en disant ça je sais bien je prends
le risque de passer à vos yeux pour une
espèce de fada mais pas de problème un
j'assume ma fat d'attitude et puis fada
fadasse et un bon mot ça vient du
provençal et ça signifie en fait celui
qui a été touché
conquis par les faits ça me va très bien
moi j'ai été touché par l'effet plutôt
tardivement c'est pas du tout pendant
l'enfance
j'avais une trentaine d'années et à
l'époque
curieusement j'ai habité à paris et
pendant mes voyages en métro eh bien je
lisais des romans arthuriens vous avez
des romans des chevaliers de la table
ronde
et c'est là que j'ai découvert mes
premières fée morgane viviane la dame du
lac et aussi merlin l'enchanteur et dans
ses ouvrages dont ces ouvrages et a
souvent des notes vous avez des renvois
en bas de page et une fois dans un de
ses ouvrages et vu qu'on faisait
référence à une fée de franche-comté
l'attend
harry
et là là là ça m'a beaucoup intrigué un
là je me suis dis il ya des faits en
franche comté et mieux que ça je me suis
rendu compte yeux qui avait pas que des
faits littéraires qui avait pas que des
faits de conte de fées mais qui avait
défait du folklore l'effet du terroir et
j'oserais même dire des vrais fait rire
en fait le déclic
le déclic de marc de ma passion on peut
dire ça pose pour le monde de l'affairé
je le dois à une jeune fille que je n'ai
jamais rencontré que je n'ai jamais vu
et dont je ne sais même pas le dans
c'est arrivé très précisément le 12
novembre 1993
et figurez vous que ce jour-là pour la
première fois de ma vie
vous allez rendre visite en fait oui à
attentes harry justement kantari elle
est un peu comme cadet rousselle vous
savez là plusieurs maisons réparties
dans toute la franche comté
elle en a une en en haute saône elle en
a une
près de tel dans le territoire de
belfort mais du côté suisse
et puis en une autre dont le doubs à
blâmant est donc ce matin novembre
j'étais l'un à blamont dans le village
j'ai vu un villageois je lui ai demandé
s'ils pouvaient m'indiquer où était la
maison de tante harry et il savait
il savait où la fée habités comme quoi
la la tradition était toujours vivante
alors donc j'ai j'ai roulé un peu et
puis j'ai fini par me garer sur un un
sentier de terre comme ça j'ai marché
encore quelques mètres et la halle un
écriteau super bien indiqué g20 vie
écrite aux grottes de ton tahri rien que
ça moi ça m'impressionnait quand même un
essai continue à marcher dans une espèce
de vallon de combes moussu avec beaucoup
de roche un peu blanchâtre comme ça
imaginez vous bien un matin de novembre
tout seul dans la forêt
j'étais pas si rassure examen et puis
enfin je suis arrivé arrivé en bas d'une
colline et en os
une énorme est vraiment une énorme
bouche de pierre
c'était l'entrée de la grotte 30 harry
elle gravit la petite colline
je suis arrivé devant cette grotte elle
était un peu un peu base au centre et un
peu courbé un peu prudent et au fond de
la grotte sur l'âme sur la gauche il y
avait un four et on voyait qu'il avait
servi un verre y avait des traces
noirâtres et on dit que c'est le four ou
temps tahri chaque année à noël fait
cuire ses gâteaux parce qu'en
franche-comté le vrai père noël s'est
tari on a un peu oublié mais c'est
dommage j'étais donc très très content
déjà de me trouver sur mon premier
monument féerique ans quand j'ai
remarqué sur la roche des petits trous
petite cavité dans laquelle on avait
glissé des des billets enfin des petits
papiers
j'ai osé en prendre un en province je
les déplier et j'ai lu mon voeu serait
d'avoir au moins une fois par an un
petit ami merci davance alors vous je
sais pas mais moi ça m'a sam a super
émue non tu te rends compte
il y avait d'autres papiers en plus il y
avait des jeunes filles à la toute fin
du xxème siècle qui venait demander un
fiancé à l'attentât non c'est autre
chose que d'aller taper un truc sur un
site de rencontres pour avoir influencé
je suis désolé est bon alors je tiens
tout de suite à dire que j'ai remis ce
petit papier soigneusement où je l'avais
pris 1 je voulais pas être responsable
du célibat de cette jeune fille non mais
ce qu'avait de vraiment étonnant c'est
que traditionnellement temps tahri est
connue pour être une entremetteuse et
donc pendant des générations des
générations toutes les jeunes filles du
coin autour de blâmont sont venus au
mois de mai apportez une boule de gui en
offrande à la tonte harry pour qu'elle
leur donne un bon mari et cette
tradition n'était pas morte
c'est la voie que vous êtes épaté elle
était toujours là
la féerie était toujours vivante
alors pour moi c'était le vrai
déclencheur je me suis dit ça c'est bien
de vivre dans l'affairé et à partir de
là les faits ne m'ont plus jamais
quitter je me suis mis à suivre leurs
traces et j'ai pénétré en fait dans un
monde enchanté
mais si les deux troublant c'est que ce
monde n'était pas un autre monde
c'était le nôtre c'était réel d'ailleurs
il suffit alors je vais vous dire un
truc peut-être que vous n'avez pas
conscience
la france est un pays féerique 1 ou 2
celui peut-être pas son nom partout dans
toutes les provinces vous allez partout
vous trouver des traces des empreintes
de fait de lutins et d'esprit des bois
il ya quantité de roches et de grottes
sentiers de deux sources de ruisseaux de
bois de chant de de près de deux hameaux
de montagne même qui portent des noms d'
fait et ça c'est quand même ça prouve
bien l'importance qu'avait le peuple
féerique pour nos ancêtres
1 parce que s'ils vivent ces empreintes
dates sont pas les empreintes
contemporaine mais cette importance des
faits pour pour nos ancêtres
j'en ai aussi pris conscience en lisant
les les ouvrages des collecteurs du 19e
siècle de tradition populaire et la
danse et où vance jr aussi une chose
tout à fait frappante
c'est que nos ancêtres les gens
d'autrefois avec quelque chose que nous
avons perdu égaré ces gens l'un avait le
merveilleux et il vivait avec holly dans
ses ouvrages qu'évidemment il croyait
aux faits aux lutins mais en plus il les
voyait il les rencontre est il les
voyait danser mais des foyers
bénéficiaient de leurs de leurs
bienfaits où il subissait il subissait
aussi des fois le courroux des faits
s'il n'avait pas un comportement adéquat
et là je me suis demandé à quoi servent
les faits aujourd'hui on les a un peu
perdu la croyance au fait elle existe
encore en islande un seul étant en
france pas terrible en islande ya encore
cinquante six pour cent de gens qui
pensent que les elfes peuvent exister
mon rêve être islandaise
et là je me suis dit oui à quoi servent
les faits bien le rôle principal a
toujours été en fait d'être les
protectrice de la nature
oui oui est même mieux d'être les
protectrices de la beauté du monde
ah ça fait un peu pompeux 1 c'est sûr
mais quand même la beauté du monde n'est
pas rien où elles ont un concept à elle
c'est l'écologie féerique et vous croyez
peut-être que c'est juste virtuel va pas
du tout j'ai juste ou prendre deux
exemples un peu exotique un pas français
mais par exemple vous avez en amérique
latine le cul rue pie ras le cul rue
piras et un elfe lutins très très
célèbre dabbagh il a les pieds à
l'envers mais c'est une caractéristique
assez courante dans ces pays magique et
le curé père il existe dans la forêt
amazonienne depuis des générations et
des générations et bien aujourd'hui
depuis une vingtaine d'années il est
devenu la mascotte l'emblème de la
défense de la faune des donc qui vivent
dans la forêt amazonienne et et vous
trouvez un peu partout son effigie il ya
même une fondation de cure pira qui
prend la défense des animaux
ailleurs au japon au japon vous avez le
cas par sais pas si vous connaissez les
cas pas est très connue au japon
il adore les cas pas c'est aussi des
lutins bon ils ont une carapace de
tortue sur le dos monsieur sinon ils
sont très sympas et les caps à eux sont
devenus donc les hommes de la même façon
la mascotte de
de la défense des cours d'eau japonais
est souvent sur les berges vous avez de
grandes de grands panneaux comme ça avec
un logo du capa qui incite les gens donc
à protéger un pas polluer les eaux des
rivières du japon ce prix dont il ya des
choses très très concrètes
on peut se servir des du peuple féerique
et c'est vrai qu'il m'arrive de rêver
qu'en france
en franche comté on ice guérir ce peuple
l'un pour aussi défendre et bien la
nature l'environnement on pourrait
imaginer que tu en arrives la vouivre
une dame verte et bien servent à protat
empêcher les décharges sauvages qu'on
voit encore régulièrement ou à protéger
contre la pollution de nos cours d'eau
et c'est vrai que être menacée par la
vouivre de son courroux je pense que ça
ferait réfléchir beaucoup
enfin pas mal de pollueurs enfin voilà
anatole france a écrit tant qu'il y aura
des bois tu es près des montagnes
des lacs des rivières tant que deux
blanches vapeur s'élèveront au dessus
des ruisseaux il y aura des nymphes des
dryades
il y aura des faits elles sont la beauté
du monde et c'est pourquoi elles ne
perdront jamais jamais
la féerie vaincra merci